[Musique]
invité de cette édition du 78 weekend
José Cruz bonsoir bienvenue sur le
plateau artiste français lusophone
humoriste à l'affiche de ha en
représentation vendredi samedi 21h au
Théâtre Darius mio à Paris et dimanche
dans les evvelines à 16h à la Royal
Factory de Versailles dans votre
département puisque vous êtes originaire
de poissie vous produirez donc à
Versailles vous êtes sur scène avec un
chanteur aussi TOS Santos vous êtes deux
sur scène et vous nous dites vouloir
créer un pont culturel entre le Portugal
et la France pour célébrer le 39e
anniversaire de la révolution portugaise
des illers comment ça se traduit sur
scène comment on traduit sur scène en
humour un sujet aussi sérieux et voire
dramatique qu'une révolution
bah justement en fait si la majorité
déjà bonjour bonsoir wilfri merci de
m'accueillir en fait la révolution a
fait que beaucoup de gens notamment
d'origine du Portugal sont arrivés en
France beaucoup dans la région
parisienne et notamment dans le 78 c'est
le cas de mes parents ils se sont
rencontrés ici il y aurait pas eu en
fait la dictature au Portugal dans les
années 60 70 il serait pas ici et donc
en fait c'est tout ça dont on a voulu
parler comment un enfant né ici suite à
la
révolution peut vivre avec humour avec
son temps c'estes contemporains des gens
qui sont d'autre origine des gens qui
sont complètement français et qui lui va
démarrer sa vie en parlant le frou
d'accord c'est un mélange français
portugais non ça c'est du tuning
d'accord frugais c'est du français parlé
par portugais d'accord et vous allez
nous montrer peut-être à quoi ça ça
ressemble quelques un quelques mots
peut-être justement bah oui bien sûr je
peux te montrer par exemple de situation
surprante et non pr une personne parlant
correctement français elle va dire ça
poopète ça ça demande beaucoup
d'attention de la part de de
l'interlocuteur vous avez face à vous
c'est un thème effectivement difficile
je vais donner redonner quelques
éléments du du contexte historique 1974
cette révolution qui met fin à la
dictature vous nous l'avez dit vos
parents étaient là-bas ils sont venus en
France ils se sont rencontrés en France
vous êtes nés en France et ils vous en
ont ils vous ont beaucoup parlé de cette
période alors c'est une période dont les
parents ont eu toujours beaucoup de mal
à parler donc nous on a bien essayé de
savoir quelques petits trucs comment ils
sont arrivés comment s'est passé la
traversée du Portugal à la France arrivé
sur Paris on sait des choses mais on
sait pas tout exactement comment ça
s'est passé parce c'est un sujet qui
reste tabou au sein des des famill qui
reste difficile parce que bah ça a été
vraiment une traversée pour certains de
plusieurs jours pas forcément officiel
et puis voyage de nuit et puis aussi
pour arriver en France fallit traverser
les Espagne qui elle de son côté
connaissait la dictature de Franco h
vous êtes retourné vous êtes allé au
Portugal à quel âge tous les étés dès
que la
révolution est arrivé tous les étés avec
la famille on retourné au Portugal euh
très content parce que ben je savais que
c'était aussi mes origines puis bah moi
j'ai commencé par parler le portugais
étant petit et comment ça s'est passé ce
retour de votre famille vous vous y
alliez pour la première fois mais de
votre famille aussi au Portugal après la
dictature alors bah justement il y a
toujours eu ce rêve chez les Portugais
de retourner un jour au pays quand les
choses iraient mieux mais en fait la
majorité des Portugais qui sont arrivés
ici finalement même nos parents ils ont
jamais la nationalité française mais ils
sont vraiment devenus comê on peut le
dire pas mal beaucoup français et vous
avez choisi de traiter tout ça dans un
spectacle humoristique tout à fait de
l'humour comment on parle d'humour
autour de ce thème quels sont les les
sujets que vous aborderé vous nous dites
ça reste parfois tabou aussi dans
certaines familles il y a des sujets des
thèmes que vous vous interdisez des des
terrains où vous n'allez pas avec ce
spectacle bah le but moi j'ai toujours
enfin moi je pense qu'on peut rire de
beaucoup de choses et qu'il faut réussir
à rire de beaucoup de choses alors moi
je prends le point de départ de toutes
les difficultés qu'ils ont eu au départ
en sadgrant c'estàd notamment barrière
au niveau de la langue barrière au
niveau de la langue qui faisait que bah
forcément il pouvait pas travailler dans
les binques tout de suite donc souvent
on leur a donné des travaux Manoel oui
on parlait du bâtiment d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure vous voyez j'ai entendu j'ai
écouté le reportage et donc c'est ça
donc je me moque un peu de ça mais avec
beaucoup de tendresse par exemple un
moment je dis dans le spectacle que que
mon papa quand il est arrivé ici
connaissait vraiment rien de la de la
France dirait qu'il a été à la Tour
Effel quand il a débarqué à Paris pas
pour visiter pour demander du travail il
croyait que c'it on échaage vous vous
jouez le spectacle en quelle langue
alors en français il a été créé en
français mais maintenant depuis 2 ans on
m'a contacté au Portugal à l'époque un
producteur pour faire une tournée en
version portugaise j'ai donc créé une
version portugaise et maintenant depuis
bah ces deux années je la joue
régulièrement et là ça va être la
première fois que bah je vais jouer pas
très loin de chez moi en version
portugaise ici à versaill la
représentation à Versailles sera en
portugais donc ça s'adresse forcément à
une communauté qui comprend le portugais
mais pleinement cette fois-ci il va
falloir suiv voici mêmeques exit
spectacle en français tout de
même tu es
portugais mer mais c'est le qui' mon
petit ché mais oui figurei que je viens
d'acheter peti B à la campagne fo00 M
quand peux commencer les
travx devant une situation
surprenanteidu parlant correctement
français
s normal et ben frontog ça donnera
Bourdel de
merde mais c'est pas
grave le plus important c'est pas la
taille non c'est sû c'est la façon de
s'en servir et
toi tu peux que
progresser
J tu t'a déjà dit quand on
veut on
pe toujours
essayer ce spectacle c'est votre
histoire aussi ah on va dire qu'il y a
une part autobiographique maintenant ça
reste un spectacle c'est aussi beaucoup
développé beaucoup de choses qui sont
arrivées autour de moi je les ai
transformé adapté à la scène pour que au
final on puisse toujours en ri même s'il
y a des moments qui ont pas toujours été
faciles par exemple pour M m parents h
mais mais vous jouez avec certains
clichés vous l'avez évoqué aussi tout à
l'heure le bâtiment par exemple les
travaux manuel des choses comme ça ça
vous a jamais agacé vous n avez pas
marre aussi qu'à chaque fois on parle du
Portugal on vous parle mais si ici ça
pas été le cas mais moi il m'est arrivé
un truc c'est véridique une fois une
journée c'était à peu près il y a un an
trois personnes différentes dans la même
journée m'ont fait la même blague sur
les Portugais trois fois bon au bout
d'un moment c'est un peu la S mais je
crois que moi la meilleure façon de
combattre les les clichés tout toutes
les moqueries qu'on peut avoir mais
approprié et puis aussi d' rire de
nous-même parce que en même temps c'est
vrai que c'est un cliché mais en même
temps c'est vrai que 70 80 VO 90 % des
Portugais sont arrivé par exemple à
cause de la langue de ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure ont pas tout de suite eu
accès à des métiers pour lesquel ils
avaient peut-être des études au Portugal
donc moi ça me dérange pas moi-même pour
financer mes études de théâtre je
remercie mes cousins j'ai fait deux
trois petites BR justement vos études
vous avez fait des études pour être
monté sur scène voilà pour mon
vérit il fallait pour vous faire ce
cursus justement en fait je pense que je
voulais aussi rassurer mes parents et
montrer que je pouvais arriver réussir
de à faire quelque chose de moi-même et
sans rien leur demander et puis en fait
bah pour payer mon école de théâtre à
Paris l'école claud Mathieu hà Claude
mon directeur de théâtre j'ai pas voulu
demander de l'argent à mes parents ça
coûte très cher une école de théâre donc
j'ai fait de l'alternance et en même
temps ça me permettait d'avoir un
diplôme de finance et avec ce que
j'économisais tous les mois je mettais
tout de côté alors que mes parents
pensaient que je dispensais tout en
discouté c'est pas vrai et à la fin
quand j'ai eu assez d'argent d'économie
et j'ai passé l'audition pour dans cette
école c'est sur Sélection j'ai passé
l'audition j'ai été pris j'ai laissé
tomber tout ce qui avait à côté et je me
suis inscrit à l'école et j'ai réalisé
mon rêve et vous vous consacrez
pleinement à ces représentations à cette
à ce spectacle qui est en représentation
je redonne la date puisque sur le
département des ivelines ce sera ce sera
ce dimanche avec une représentation en
portugais là vous vous adressez
forcément à la communauté portugaise
mais au-delà de ça lorsque le spectacle
est joué en français vous vous adressez
à qui est-ce que ce sont justement des
gens qui qui connaissent ces
problématiques que vous avez rencontré
et que vous détournez ces clichésquel
vous tout à fait alors en fait qui pass
inéress non justement justement en
version française et puis en fait pour
tout pour tout te dire on pluser c'est
plus Simp mon cher Wilfried la première
année quand j'ai créé le spectacle pour
tout dire j'avais quasiment pas de
public portugais ou l'zophone tout
simplement comme moi c'estàd né ici ça a
été on va dire que les allez 400 500 600
premiers spectateurs les les premières
semaines mais ça a été juste du public
francophone qui habitu le one man show
et puis c'est que petit à petit bouche
oreille où ils sont arrivés et jamais le
spectacle a été con comme justement comm
uneuteur parce que j'ai pas voulu non
plus parler que de ça dans ce spectacle
fil rouge a fait sur mes origines parce
SPP
Jos on peut pas échapper il y a des
questions des interrogations qui se
posent après audelà de ça justement pour
combattre les clichés l'idée cétait
aussi de montrer qu'on était mais
complètement intégré qu'on a si je te
dis que si je te dis pas que je suis
portugais tu vas pas me le dire oh tiens
toi tu es portugais bon sauf si j'avais
une Trelle à la main mais de sur scène
je voudrais aussi qu'on prenne le temps
tout même de parler de Tos Santos parce
que vous êtes de sur scène et lui c'est
plus sur la la partie musicale parler un
petit peu de lui tout fait alors toazb
en fait il y a 2 ans on faisant la
tournée au Portugal il a entendu parler
du spectacle on a fait connaissance il
se trouve qu'on avait qu'on aille
toujours une amie une commune Betti que
j'embrasse qui participe à la création
de cet événement ce pont culture la
tierscique artistique et on s'est dit
que ça serait bien que lui avec son
univers musical euh chanson création et
les compositeurs auteur notamment de son
premier album solo qui est qui sort en
ce moment benah qu'on réussisse à faire
quelque chose ici en France et puis
aussi après à terme au Portugal et qu'on
fasse cet échange de deux enfants nés
après la Révolution chacun en mélangeant
nos univers le mettant en les réunissant
sur scène moi je le connaissais parce
que en 2008 ici on sait pas trop en
France mais en 2008 son single a été
classé numéro 1 Top 50 il a un succès
énorme des millions de VU et on s'est
dit bah allez on tente tous les deux on
fait un truc ensemble et t il chante
très bien il est très beau garçon il
sera là dimanche il fait la première
partie on va l'écouter justement voilà
pour ceux qui voudrai venir dimanche
vida em Câmara lenta
[Musique]
880 sinto que
ergir se de coror todas as canções de
amor para
conquist
partir vez que tenho
cé não me
deixes
mal não
me no livro que eu
não no filme que eu não
VI fot onde eu não
entrei
notícia
[Musique]
j vous êtes deux sur scène on a
découvert en plateau José Cruz on a
découvert votre compare sur scène qui
lui est plutôt porté sur la musique et
vous serez tous les deux présents
dimanche à Versailles pour le spectacle
il sera joué en portugais vous me disiez
lorsqu'on écoutait ce ce morceau que le
spectacle devrait arriver en français
aussi prochainement Roy vers
ce ser l'as plus l de venir découvrir à
cette occasion vous défendez les
couleurs du Portugal leillet de la Révol
vous AZ le avec vous leer rouge sur
votre polo est-ce que vous imaginez
ensuite la suite de votre carrière sans
justement bah se jouer de de ces clichés
sans défendre cette communauté
portugaise en en vous ouvrant vers
d'autres thma ou tout à fait je suis
déjà en train de réfléchir à des
nouveaux sketchs pour un autre spectacle
en même temps c'est vrai que celui-ci je
pensais qu'il ferait que de mois c'était
pour réaliser mon rêve il se trouve
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui on est déjà à 4
ans de représentation près de 300
représentations plus de 15000
spectateurs maintenant il y a des
tournées à travers toute la France Nice
bientôt Grenoble fontaine notamment
Marseille Strasbourg en discussion VO a
tout plein de choses alors en fait je
m'attendais pas à ça donc pour l'instant
j'en profite on tourne on va un peu
partout je vais peut-êtreement retourner
donc très vite au Portugal avec TOS et
puis mais c'est vrai que je commence
déjà à penser à d'autres choses je parle
aait pas forcément de la communauté
portugaise merci José Cruz one man show
donc et puis sur scène puisqu'on a
entendu toute
j'ai oublié son
prénom pardon à lui vous serez de sur
scène Royal Factory ce weekend dimanche
et puis dès ce soir parce que l'émission
est en direct si vous nous suivez le
vendredi vous serez sur scène ce soir à
Paris Merci à VOUS àe l'équipe